. We have a voicemail number. That number is
two one nine two David P.. Here's a caller
who thinks Trump really will leave the country
if he loses next week. Take a listen to this.
Hey, David. Joe from California. As you know,
with everything with Trump, it's projection.
And I think every time he now has been saying over
Luzon, leave the country. Yes, he means it because
he knows he's under several state investigations.
A person with a New York d.a.'s office. True.
And a few other things going on. So I think
he knows I'm going to lose. I'd better leave
the country because otherwise I won't be
able to pardon myself on state charges.
I'm going to leave the country. So for protection.
Yeah. I actually I talked to a few friends
over the weekend and they were saying
the same thing that they're thinking Trump
really will leave the country, although their
thought was, you know, not these more cartoonish,
like I'll go hide out in Russia, which I just
don't think that's going to happen. But more
like Trump will permanently relocate to like his
Scottish golf course or something like that again.
I think there are many countries that would love
to welcome a former U.S. president who's going
to criticize potentially the election system that
gets his opponent elected. But we're very much
getting ahead of ourselves. All we have to do
now is vote. We'll deal with if and where Trump
will go to live later. Let's first take care of
business on the bonus show today. Mike Pence
has five aides, including his chief of staff,
tested positive for Kovik, 19. Number two, grocery
stores are preparing for a second sort of buying
panic as we get into rapidly climbing cases now
in the fall into winter. And a Boston ballot box,
much like the one I used, has been set on fire.
The city putting out a message saying if you
dropped off your ballot during a certain range of
times, please contact us, because it appears as
though some ballots have quite literally gone up
in smoke. All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Get instant access, instant to the
bonus show by signing up at join Pacman dot com.
I look forward to speaking to you
then and or on tomorrow's show.